you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome Cory
Inkpen research manager and principal
researcher Microsoft Research good
morning I hope you enjoyed last night
welcome to the second day of the
Microsoft research faculty summit today
promises to be just as exciting as it
was yesterday to start today it is my
pleasure to introduce dr. Amy Greenwald
who is a associate professor of computer
science from Brown University Amy also
spent time as a visiting researcher at
Microsoft Research New York Amy's been
widely recognized for her work and she
was named a Fulbright Scholar and was
awarded a Sloan research fellowship in
2002 amy was nominated for the
presidential Early Career Award for
scientists and engineers and was named
one of CIA's digital government Fellows
please join me in welcoming Amy Thank
You Lori good morning everyone
thank you for waking up to be here or
perhaps like me you're on East Coast
time and you're awake anyway if you came
to hear about deep learning I'm sorry to
disappoint
I have nothing beyond that to say about
deep learning well it's always a
pleasure to be here in Redmond I was on
leave as Corey mentioned visiting
Microsoft in New York but with here for
tech fest a couple of years ago and in
fact one of the results I'll talk about
we discovered I think just outside this
room during a coffee break so my
research is primarily concerned with
multi-agent systems in the sense that I
study systems where multiple agents both
AI and humans interact with one another
and in general all these agents are
assumed to be strategic so this means
that they're endowed with some
objectives and they asked so is to
achieve those objectives so this is the
exact same behavioral model that
underlies much of game theory so
computer scientists like myself often
borrow ideas
from game series to apply to our
multi-agent system research and likewise
we sometimes make contributions to game
theory and in fact during today's talk I
will talk about one such contribution
and let me warn you that that part of
the talk is if it's technical I hope
everyone has their coffee so and then
during the second half I'll transition
to talking about kind of straight-up AI
so as you are no doubt aware there have
been tremendous advances in recent years
in applying AI to social good in
healthcare and education etc and
likewise there have been advances in
applying an area of game theory called
mechanism design to social good in
healthcare in education etc so I'm going
to start today by telling you about some
of these successful deployments and then
I'll transition to talking about some of
the remaining challenges and give some
suggestions as to how we might tackle
them so what is this mechanism design so
well for starters what the mechanism
mechanism is a game in the game
theoretic sense that means that it's
rules by which some outcome will be
determined after the participating
strategic agents take action but
particularly to mechanism design is the
idea that each agent has access to some
private information and that their
action in the mechanism is going to
involve reporting some function of that
private information to the center who is
the entity implementing the mechanism so
for example plurality voting for
determining the outcome of an election
is a mechanism and in an election the
putting agents private information is
may be their ranking of all the
candidates and then their action might
be for example to report their most
preferred candidates and then in
plurality voting in particular the
winner is declared as the candidate who
receives the most votes
so the mechanism design problem then is
to design a good mechanism in some sense
so in the case of voting a good
mechanism would be one who elects a
candidate who is preferred by the voters
in aggregate our Electoral College has
come under some serious criticism this
century for electing presidents who are
not preferred by the majority of
so some would say that that is not a
good mechanism design another desirable
property of mechanisms is that they
elicit truth-telling behavior so if for
example you're a supporter of Bernie
Sanders you should not be incentivized
to vote for Hillary Clinton you should
be free to vote your conscience if a
mechanism is not truth-telling then it
can be expected to be a good mechanism
because it can determine an outcome that
reflects the participating agents
preferences if it doesn't know those
preferences so in short a mechanism is a
set of rules for determining an outcome
based on reports by the participating
agents about their private information
and then the mechanism design problem is
to design a mechanism that achieves some
goal and doing so usually requires
truth-telling or something close to it
because a good outcome can't be
generated by false reports so like the
old adage says garbage in garbage out so
as our first example of the successful
deployment of a mechanism let's discuss
kidney exchanges so currently there are
roughly 100,000 people queued up for
kidney transplants in the United States
and kidney is like other organs are
donated by the deceased but
interestingly they can also be donated
by the living because people can live
with just one kidney and indeed it's
quite common for family members to
volunteer a kidney to save a loved one
the trouble is not all kidneys are
compatible and to complicate matters
more some kidneys are more compatible
than others so it could well happen that
I need a kidney and say my husband's
kidney he's going to donate for me is
not particularly compatible with me but
maybe Cory's partner also needs a kidney
and Cory's kidney is not compatible with
her but perhaps Cory's kidney is
compatible with me and my husband's with
her partners so under these
circumstances a trade can be arranged
like you see here and indeed there can
be 3/4 way etc trade so facilitating
these trades is a goal of kidney
exchanges so how is this a mechanism
design problem well the organizers of
the exchange will announce some rule
which matches will be made and the goal
then is to match as many kidneys to
patients as possible truth-telling
welfare maximizing so making the most
matches mechanisms do exist for certain
variants of this problem
like when donor recipient repair pairs
will report their preferences to the
center directly but in most
implementations hospitals are the ones
that do the reporting and hospitals
might decide to do their own internal
matching first and then report just kind
of the leftover pairs to the center and
those can be harder to match so you can
see the truth-telling is maybe not quite
there and so as a result you may not get
the optimal trade the most trades you
could possibly get in in that setting
but still kidney exchanges are up and
running and facilitating many trades and
saving many lives a second example of
the use of mechanism design in practice
is in the realm of school choice so for
those of you who don't have school-age
children I do school choice is an
attempt to allocate students to public
schools according to the students or
perhaps more accurately the parents
preferences over schools rather than
allocating them in the traditional way
which was just by neighborhood which can
sometimes leave children who live in
neighborhoods with underfunded schools
with less than ideal options so in a
typical school choice implementation
parents submit to the district a list of
their top K schools in order and
likewise the schools will rank students
so they'll rank them for example by who
lives in their walk zone or they might
rank them by siblings having priority
things like this so then a matching
algorithm processes all these rankings
and assign students to schools much like
how residents are assigned Hospital so
these problems these problems are
instances of the heterosexual stable
marriage problem where the goal is to
discover a matching of men to women such
that there are not two matched pairs and
we can imagine two matched pairs for
which a swap would be preferable for
some of the people in the matching cause
if there was such a swap the matching
would be unstable because that pair
would run off animal so as
case of kidney exchanges truth-telling
welfare magnet mechanisms do exist for
this setting but in practice speaking as
a parent the implementation of school
choice in Providence in particular has
had an unfortunate effect in particular
it's led to a kind of breakdown of
community so the problem is that we
report only the short ordinal ranking of
schools but there's no language to
report how important it is for us to
actually have our children ascent
attending the same schools as our as our
neighbors so this may seem reasonable
because school choices course was
designed to give students an opportunity
to escape different river hoods but in
Providence at least school choice is
having the effect of cutting up
neighborhoods and it seems to click
potentially harm the students more than
it's helping at least some of them and
of course as the added problems with the
busing costs that are extreme because of
the school choice and the time you know
kids will be picked up at 6:30 in the
morning for a school that starts at 8
o'clock so the time they waste on the
bus but I'm not going to go off on a
political commentary here I just wanted
to remark on the dimensionality of the
preference reports so just like in
voting you might have complicated
preferences over all the candidates you
can report only one in certain
mechanisms in school choice likewise we
might have complicated preferences over
the schools and the combinations of
students that are attending the school
but we can report only that shortlist so
and as always a mechanism design the
extent to which an outcome is good can
only be as good as its input okay I now
want to move on to a third application
of mechanism design which is optimal
option design and I'm going to go into a
bit more detail here as I'm going to
need this to explain some of the results
later on so here's the framework for
optimal auction design so first of all
we'll start with an auction so an option
is announced for some Goods and bidders
are going to report their preferences to
pay for the goods and so this is a
mechanism design problem again because
the bidders have some private
information about their values for the
goods the bidders also have utilities
and the
utilities of the difference between the
value of what will be allocated to them
and what they pay
and now the auction designers goal at
least in the so called optimal auction
design problem the goal is to maximize
the total payment so there are other
objectives that you could consider for
example maximizing welfare but the
optimal auction is the one that
maximizes optimal is used to mean the
one that maximizes payments and this
makes sense for example if your
Microsoft and you're running advertising
auctions you want to maximize your
revenue okay so where as I said we're
going to do this a little more formally
because I'll need this for some of my
results so more formally we have n ages
and they all have private values these
private values are drawn iid from some
distribution and then the bidders are
going to use some strategy to notice
here s to buy next strategy is a
function of their private information so
that strategy is going to determine
their bids so then the auctioneer will
collect this V which is supposed to be
bold I hope you can see that that's bold
that's a vector of bids one per agent
and so then the auction designer has to
design the auction so what is an auction
consists of an auction consists of two
things it consists of an X and a P and X
is the allocation rule so that is how
we're going to Turman winner is of the
goods one in this case actually we're
just doing a single good so who's going
to win the good and P is the payment so
that's going to determine how what
they're going to pay to for their
winnings so X and P are the main
variables that we have to design in
designing our auction so as we said the
utilities are going to be determined
it's been depending on what you win and
how much you pay so in particular there
seem to be linear here and so it's the
value that you have that your private
value for the good times your your
allocation so you can imagine the
allocation X being maybe it's an
indivisible good and you're kind of
allocated or you're not it could be a
zero one thing or maybe it's a
probability of being allocated so maybe
it's in the range of 0 1 so your this is
your positive term for your value times
what you're allocated minus
what you have to pay for whatever for
participating in the auction okay so
that's the model and then kind of the
standard equilibrium concept for this
model it's called the Bayes Nash
equilibrium probably many of you have
heard of Nash equilibrium Bayes Nash is
just it's Bayesian because we have
uncertainty here in that the private
values are not known they're drawn from
a distribution so Bayes Nash equilibrium
is like Nash equilibrium only we're
taking expectations everywhere so just
to remind you what Nash equilibrium is
Nash equilibrium everybody's best
responding to one another so that means
that all the players are utility
maximizing given what everybody else is
doing so Bayes Nash same thing but in
expectation alright so here is the
optimization problem stated slightly
more formally again to design an auction
you have to choose an X to the P so
that's what our decision variables are
here our objective is to maximize our
expected payments as I mentioned and
then we have a bunch of constraints so
let's start with the last constraint
last constraint ex-post feasibility this
means that we can't allocate more than
we have okay that makes sense we also
have an individual rationality
constraint this says that everybody's
utilities in expectation that's what
interim means will be non-negative okay
so everybody will be willing to
participate voluntarily
and the last constraint is the one that
has to do with truth-telling which we
said was one of the features we're
looking for in in mechanisms and so we
want to make sure that telling the truth
is in fact utility maximizing and these
top two constraints are basically
defining what it means to be in Bayes
Nash equilibrium so what we want here
are these payments you'll notice they
depend on the bids which were equal to
this sov thing so this is this is SV is
there to denote that everybody is
playing an equilibrium strategy alright
so again we're looking for auction rules
here so that's X and P such that in that
auction when everybody is playing
equilibrium so we're anticipating the
behavior of the agents when everybody is
playing their equilibrium strategy that
the payments in total are maximized all
right that's the problem it wasn't that
easy to explain it's a hard problem to
solve
but Meyerson solved it in a very elegant
way which I'll show you on the next
slide but basically the gist of it is
that he introduced what's called a
reserve price so we reserve price is
going to be some price below which you
are not willing to sell the good so the
good you know you might think well I'll
just you know it's not worth anything to
me I'll sell it for whatever but what
Meyerson showed is that if you choose an
appropriate reserve price that that's
what you need to do in order to solve
this problem optimally so how did he do
that he did that with that very ugly
theorem that I apologize for not having
a picture of if you want me to explain
this I don't have time now but I'm happy
to do it in the halls afterwards but let
me just tell you what he's done here is
that he's fully characterized Bayes Nash
equilibria in this problem and so how
has he done it he's done it with these
two properties the first property says
that the allocation rule has to be
monotonic in your valuation this makes a
lot of sense the higher the valuation
the higher the likelihood that you're
going to be allocated
okay so monocot and monotonicity in
valuations is the first property and
then the second property says once you
have that the payments are given by this
ugly formula so the payments are
entirely specified by that formula on
this slide so for once you've stated
what your allocation rule is you know
for sure that these are the only
payments that are going to give you the
bay's Nash equilibrium solution they
have to be these payments okay so that
was sort of his his brilliant insight
and falling out of this is something
called the revenue equivalence theorem
the revenue equivalence theorem says
that once you settle on an allocation
rule all your auctions are going to
yield the same revenue so why is that
it's exactly because of this because
here we see you see this X hat here the
X hat shows up in this payment's
identity formula and so it has to be
once you pick your X hat these has to be
the payments so why is this interesting
think about the auctions that you may
have heard of in passing first prize
second price and so on so how do these
work so a first price auction is the
kind of auction that you know when
you're going to buy a house you're going
to bid on a house and you're looking at
the house and you love this house and
it's worth $250,000 to you you think but
of course you want to pay less
than what it's worth to you so you think
about you know how should I shave my did
I don't want to give the full thing
because I have to pay whatever I did so
maybe you bid $200,000 for the house
instead and if you're lucky you win it
you walk away with that utility of
$50,000 so that's the first price
auction where you pay what you bid
an alternative is a second price auction
in a second price auction you pay not
what you bid but you win if you have the
highest bid but you pay the second
highest price this is a lot like what
you see on eBay in eBay when you're
bidding has that proxy agent who's
bidding for you and they'll be it up to
epsilon above what the second highest
bidder is so that's basically a second
price auction what's being run on eBay
so what this theorem is telling us is
that first price auction and second
price auctions they have the same
allocation rule they always allocate to
the highest bidder and since they have
the same allocation rule they're
actually going to yield the same revenue
and so that's true a first price second
price third price and so on and even of
what are called all pay auctions and
then all pay auction everybody has to
pay even if you don't win they all get
the same revenue okay that was your
crash course on auction design so so far
what I've talked about is lots of Nobel
laureate worthy research so I should
mention that the ideas of school choice
were introduced by Milton Friedman and
really advocated and pushed forward by
Al Roth these are all Nobel laureate
economists also Gale and Shapley were
involved I think Gail's died before he
could earn the Nobel Prize but I'll
mention that he did that work while he
was at Brown and this most recent
serum.this Meyerson story with the
optimal''option design he also just
recently won a Nobel Prize for that work
as well so that was all the super
interesting stuff that was Nobel
laureate now comes myself okay
we'll see how that goes all right so I
went into all that detail on optimal
options because it's very related to
optimal contest design which is
something I want to talk to you about
so contests are commonly used to spur
innovation so you might have heard or
learned in your readings that the
British Parliament passed something
called the longitude the longitude act
in 1714 and offered some serious
prize money to anyone who could devise a
method of precisely determining a ship's
longitude as while out at sea and
another example of a prize that would
spur innovation is the wolf skill prize
which was introduced by Paul wolf
apparently the story goes the public
rock rafael perhaps that he had planned
a suicide but somehow stayed up all
night trying to prove Fermat's Last
Theorem and sort of some maybe missed
the hour of his planned suicide so when
he the next morning he rewrote his what
will offering a 100 how much does it say
it doesn't say sorry hundreds anyone
know a hundred thousand pound no no no
not in townsville yeah a hundred
thousand Jewish Marx right for anyone
who could prove for a math lesson which
was awarded of course in 1990 and
there's a local prize which is for
anyone who can pass the Turing test okay
oh sorry all right and so what is the
optimal contest design problem always it
was stated by Gault in actually in 1900
or at least some variants of it so here
is how he described the problem a
certain sum say 100 pounds is available
for two prizes to be awarded at a
forthcoming competition the larger one
for the first of the competitors and the
smaller for the second how should the
hundred pounds be most suitably divided
between the two what ratio should a
first prize bear to a second and does it
depend on the number of competitors okay
so this is an optimal contest design
problem but you could think of as an
optimal mechanism design so let's look
at this problem and we'll try to as I
explained it you can try to relate it
back to what I said about auctions so
our contest with some rewards is
announced this is like an auction is
announced
so competitors are going to make a
choice about the degree of effort they
wish to expend to produce their contest
entry so this is like the bids that the
bidders are going to submit in the
auction
the competitors abilities are going to
be their private information so they
have some skill they have some talent
and maybe the person running the contest
doesn't know what that is that's private
to the
and so these abilities though are then
going to encode a mapping from their
effort how much effort they put in to
the quality of their submission and then
they'll get some utilities the utilities
depends on the rewards they win and and
the effort expended and then their goal
of course is to design a contest that's
going to kind of elicit the greatest
contribution so the maximum effort from
all of the participants so that is the
contest designers goal so one way to
think of this as I mentioned already we
want to relate to this to auctions but
in particular we're going to relate this
to all pay options so in an auto-pay
auction as I mentioned everybody has to
pay so what's an example of a contest
that we've all participated in we've all
participated in NSF grant writing
contest right so in these contests we
all pay I hope I pay a lot dearly every
time right so we put in all of this
effort to write our grants we have to
pay and we may or may not be rewarded so
that's how you can think of a contest as
an all pay auction and here we have the
model which is again very similar to the
model that we saw before so we have a
bunch of agents and they have their
private skill levels and here's just one
difference between what we saw before
and and what we have now so we have this
effort they're going to invest and we
have we're explaining the contribution
which is going to be this quality of
their submission that's describing their
contribution as a function of their
private skill level which is the V times
the effort that they choose to expend
okay so that is everybody's effort and
then because it's all pay so X again
denotes rewards either note your effort
because it's all pay everybody's paying
so everybody will get their rewards
maybe and they are going to be charged
for the effort that they expend okay so
this connection here will actually this
stuff on the next slide was noted by
jalwa
Heartland and Saban so in particular
what they noted was that we can think of
that all pay auction which is kind of
like a reverse auction we're sort of
eliciting submissions here I'm going to
pick one of these you can think of that
also as a forward usual auction
just by multiplying the utilities by the
private values so if we do a little
algebra here we take the utilities which
were x i - e I and we multiply them by
these what we can do what we can see is
that we recover our kind of usual
utility function the utility function I
had maybe five slides ago for auctions
which was that we were going to achieve
our V our value times our allocation -
our payment and here our payment is a Q
instead of a P because we're paying in
the quality of the submission that we
submit so what's the point the point now
is that we've converted our contest
which was an all pay auction into a
forward auction here and then we can
solve it in the usual way that Meyerson
has solved the optimal auction so we
solve as an optimal auction and in this
forward auction you know here here's how
this works but in short you know it will
set some optimal reserve and we will
have a solution in Bayes Nash
equilibrium with a formula that looks a
lot like the formula from the payments
identity before it's been modified
slightly to accommodate reserve prices
okay so that problem was solved so we
were thinking about that problem but
noticing that the way people work often
you may have heard of this often follows
this so-called 8020 rule
so the 80/20 rule says that in 20% of
our efforts for 20% of our effort we can
produce 80% of our results so in other
words more and more once we've done that
20% whatever we're doing beyond that it
becomes much harder to achieve any
further results so we have increasing
marginal costs in this in this model so
we went back to that contest design
thinking about this 80/20 rule as the
model of our effort so the way this
works is basically the way we had it
before except that now we have this C
function which you can think of either
as increasing marginal cost as I just
described some convex function like that
or as kind of diminishing marginal
returns on your effort so that's the
inverse of the function right so we have
the more effort you are contributing
your your returns are not increasing
here they're increasing by less and less
all right so we are going to solve or
tend to solve the same problem that we
just saw how it we solve but this time
with these concave or convex costs
whichever way you look at it alright so
we're going to do the same thing that we
did before which is multiply our values
of the private values times of utilities
and so we recover this thing which kind
of looks like what we had before but it
has this annoying C hanging around all
right so first of all how are you so how
we going to solve this well we need to
know what the optimal auction is
unfortunately we don't know what the
optimal auction is and even after
working on the problem for a year or two
we still don't know what the optimal
auction is but maybe someone here can
solve for this optimal auction so in the
mean time we're going to do the the best
we can doing something similar to what
we saw before solving for again a Bayes
Nash equilibrium and and seeing seeing
how that how that fares all right so how
do we proceed well we proceed like
Meyerson proceeded we derive meyerson's
results again the same characterization
but again we have this annoying C in
there so it's not quite what we want
because we're interested in payments and
we get a result that's kind of about
this C adjusted payments which is not
quite what we're looking for but then
the key observation that we made right
outside here in the hallway is this one
on this slide so we have this kind of
annoying see here we're interested in
the key that we're interested in
maximizing the queues the queues are our
payments this is the quality of our
submissions that's the thing that we
want to maximize here but we have this
annoying C there so we kind of have to
invert that somehow so looking here you
know obviously Q is equal to the NC
inverse of C of Q so that seems pretty
clear but what we noticed outside the
kind of minor thing but important is
that we can pop this C outside the
expectation because of yangsun's
inequality and so since we can pop a C
outside the expectation what this is
telling us we want to maximize this
quantity over here those are all the
payments and so what we can do instead
is we can take as our payment C inverse
of all this junk and we can take those
as our payments and that's only going to
get us more revenue than we had before
okay so we can do the inverse thing on
the outside here and that can only make
us happier so that was good news for us
all right so we have a rough idea of
what the payments are going to be in
this auction we're design
the next question then is what is the
allocation rule going to be because the
payments as we've been thinking about
them here remember they have this X hat
in them they're fully specified once you
know the allocation rule you know your
payments they're given by the payments
identity and so what we need to do then
is we need to figure out an interesting
allocation rule or an appropriate
allocation rule it turns out to be
interesting No so first thing we did was
we saw about a bunch of examples and
here's something that we noticed we set
up a kind of crazy example and in our
crazy example what we were able to show
was that if you allocate to the highest
bidder so remember in first and second
price auctions you were always
allocating to the highest bidder if we
allocated to the highest bidder in our
example we had a mechanism our mechanism
achieved the fourth root of N in revenue
on the other hand if we allocated
completely randomly just do you want to
form random we were able to get square
root of n revenue okay so we're doing
you know where we have this rate of
decay to zero between the ratio between
these two things and what we're showing
here is just allocating randomly in this
setting is better than allocating to the
best visit to the highest bidder
ok and decaying to 0 all right so that
gave us some ideas to think about as to
how we might want to allocate in this
this auction set up and so what we came
up with finally was that we are going to
allocate uniformly at random to all
competitors who are in the top quartile
okay so now that in that example we
could have we were just doing a
uniformly at random you might think that
you want to do just maybe the top half
and that's probably also a good choice
for us the math worked out a little bit
easier just allocating to the top
quartile so that's how we did it but in
any case the point is we're not
allocating to just the best just the
highest bidder we're allocating
uniformly random to anybody in the top
quartile and so now we have you know
some theorems that say doing this is a
Bayes Nash equilibrium that's good and
moreover doing this is a constant
approximation of the optimal again I
don't know the optimal we had an upper
bounds on the optimal constant
approximation of of that and so that's
also good and so I think the takeaway
message here is something that was
characterized by a professor at
Northwestern called minor he talks about
something called the discouragement
effect which I think is
is maybe what we're seeing so what he
said was high-powered incentives in a
relative performance world can actually
destroy effort in particular since the
less talented are less likely to win
under competitive high-powered
incentives they may give up and he
dubbed this the discouragement effect
and in contrast the most talented do
increase their efforts when tasting
sharper incentives so there's also the
incentive effect so it turns out that in
many settings the discouragement effect
dominates the incentive effects and
that's basically what we're seeing here
that prescribing softer incentives is
better and the greatest overall effort
can be elicited then by pushing more
rewards towards the lower performers
okay so that was our conclusion as well
and something that he saw in in his work
simultaneously okay so that kind of
concludes my discussion of optimal
contests and of mechanism design and I
want to change gears now well actually
is still a little more mechanism sign
but I want to change gears and talk talk
a little bit more about data and
inference all right so maybe I'll pause
for a sip of water and then continue
all right so underlying that entire
story was the assumption that we knew
the distribution of values or the
distribution of abilities of the
participants in the mechanism so this is
not generally true we can't generally
assume this but one thing that we do
have a lot of these days our data so
here we're looking at a simulation of a
first price auction where all we have
are the data we don't have the
underlying distribution so the question
is what can we do can we design an
optimal auction with just from just the
data so in this simulation we have 200
runs of a first price auction we're
drying so in the simulation of course we
know the the underlying values so in the
simulation we're drawing some values but
the conclusions we're going to make are
assuming we don't have that distribution
so here's a bunch of samples from those
of how these bids are showing up and you
see that the revenue matches the higher
bid in in in each of the two columns
right because it's a first price auction
so it asked the question from the data
can we find the optimal auction so can
we make that work so here's the first
attempt at that so of course the optimal
auction remember I said this earlier it
uses some kind of reserve price so to
find the optimal auction the question is
what reserves should we set and so
here's a couple of choices maybe we'll
set point five maybe we'll set point
seven five and here we are re running
through our data with the point five and
point seven five and figuring out what
our revenue is and what we find is I
know for example here at point seven
five we're getting zero here why is that
because neither of these agents have bid
above point seven five so we're running
kind of a broken simulation here right
we're sort of what we're doing is we're
just by introducing this reserve price
we're just zeroing out a bunch of our
entries because any time that these bids
don't turn out above the reserve we end
up with zero so from this simulation as
it is right now it looks like
introducing a reserve price is a bad
thing to do but that's of course because
we're doing this wrong this is the first
price auction remembering a first price
auction you shade your bids remember the
housing example earlier right you don't
bid your full value so what we need to
know in order to do this kind of
optimization is we need to know what
we're driving those bids so we need to
invert that big function to back out the
values that motivated that behavior so
if you do that then you find that in
fact by introducing reserve price is 0.5
0.75 you can see that revenue is
actually going up does that make sense
in the first cases you know we were just
throwing stuff away because we were just
looking at the business they are in this
case we first backed out the values we
figured out what values were motivating
the behavior then we introduced a
reserve price and recomputed the
equilibrium so these these days are now
these revenues are coming in under new
bids that were using the values and
using the reserve that we were testing
in in each of the columns all right so
we can do this repeatedly and we can see
that you know as you increase your
reserve price your revenue in
equilibrium is going up for a while and
then eventually going down okay so this
exercise is effective as long as you
take your big data and from your big
data you back at your values so that you
can then push them forward in the new
equilibrium that you are considering all
right so all of that conversation leads
us to inverse reinforcement learning
which of course is about exactly this
about backing out values so we've been
working at Brown a whole bunch of
collaborators and as part of the human
humanity centers robotic initiative on
some human robot collaboration and for
this we are using inverse reinforcement
learning meaning we are backing out
values again to see what motivates what
drives certain behaviors so many of you
probably know this we'll do it quickly
inverse reinforcement learning is
usually studied in the framework of
Markov decision processes and so a
Markov decision process is a model where
an agent is operating in a state and the
agent can then take some action after
taking that action they will transition
stochastic lis to some other state and
likewise we'll stochastically receive
some rewards and this process is
repeating so in an MVP you're typically
given the stage you're given the actions
you're giving the transactions you're
given the reward
given everything everything is fully
specified and your objective is to find
an optimal policy which means an optimal
mapping from States to actions what you
should do at every state lots there are
lots of examples of MVPs I'm sure you're
familiar with many of them I usually
talk about the recycling robot in my
classes you know that one he used to go
around from office to office collecting
the coke cans and deciding if you should
go and recycle his battery or go collect
more coke cans for more rewards well I
try to you know update myself a little
bit so I found another more up-to-date
example here this is the robot bartender
who apparently is also run by an MVP so
this is not a robot bartender who's like
a coffee machine but you kind of select
that like a vodka on the rocks and that
kind of comes out you know from the
machine and a coffee machine style this
is a robot who's actually trying to
anticipate
oh that that patron over there would
like to be served and that one is
willing to wait a little bit longer and
I should really get to this guy and he
has been served already he hasn't and so
on and so has all of this in his state
and it's being controlled by an MVP in
the background all right so I've of
course mostly get interested in games so
we are thinking about this inverse
reinforcement learning in a slightly
more general context which is in a
context of Markov games so a Markov game
generalize them this is a Markov
decision process again you have a state
but now you have multiple agents so your
multiple agents are all taking actions
simultaneously and then they will
transition to some other state and they
will all get rewards so here are some
examples of Markov games that we've
thought about so in these games they're
Grid games obviously so in these games
we have yellow and blue agents and the
yellow existed we're showing the initial
states of the games here so the yellow
and blue agents in this first game are
starting off on one another's goal so
the yellow agents has a yellow square as
its goal the blue agent has a Blue
Square as its goal so for example in
this hallway game they're trying to get
from you know to cross each other in the
hallway they can't cross each other in
the hallway if they bump in bump into
each other they just kind of keep
bouncing back or
so they have to figure out some way to
kind of get around one another to get to
their respective goals so this is kind
of maybe a model for when you're walking
down the streets and you see somebody in
front of you and you kind of don't know
if you want to go this way or go that
way and you're kind of you know back and
forth on that all right and all of these
games are like this in all of the games
the way that they're set up you know the
blue agents is being blocked from his
goal the yellow agent is all in his way
and likewise this yellow agent wants to
get his goal but he's left by the blue
agent all right so we've primarily done
experiments with this first game the
hallway game and interestingly I went to
a women in machine learning workshop
your two ago and ran into Joelle Kino
and she has she's building a smart
wheelchair and her swar wheelchair she
said have to solve exactly this problem
the wheelchairs kind of rolling down the
hall and a person is coming the other
way and it kind of has to figure out
which way it wants to go to avoid the
person who's who's approaching it all
right
and moreover she's attempting to build
these wheelchairs that are adapted to
the user's needs so again to adapt
something to the user's needs you need
to know something about their rewards
their values like what is motivating
their behavior so maybe IRL is
applicable there as well all right so
how are we going to build a robot that
is going to collaborate with a human now
a couple of strategies approaches we
might take so first thing we did here is
on the hallway game we ran a bunch of
experiments on Mechanical Turk and in
these experiments we just observed
humans behavior and ultimately kind of
clustered it this was done just manually
we sort of looked at the behaviors and
decided whether people were looking like
they're mostly competitive you know just
trying to get to their own goal or
whether they were sort of friendly and
trustworthy and maybe waiting for the
opponent to also get to their goal or
maybe they just give up and only want
the opponents because there go all of
these different types of behaviors and
so we looked at this actually with two
different treatments in the first
treatment the individual reasoning
treatment each of the players would get
100 points if they reach their goal and
so you see kind of a nice wide
distribution of behaviors when you have
this individual the individual reasoning
treatment in the team treatment
we change the payoff so that you could
only get the hundred points if your
opponent also got to their goal okay and
not surprisingly you get a lot more
cooperation when you are only going to
get your points when your opponent also
gets legal so we were sort of able to
manipulate humans by changing their
rewards to make them friendlier so we
also do the same thing with two learners
we also ran experiments just with the
ages and again we manipulated rewards
some so what you're looking at here is
you're looking at runs with a selfish
and with a more fair agent which is the
one with the rewards that have been
manipulated and so this the selfish
agent just gives 100 points when he hits
the goal but the fairer agent has this
reward function where he has his initial
his own reward that's our a for the
agents but then he gets a penalty if his
reward is very different than his
opponent's reward okay so we kind of
made things a little bit Sarah by giving
you a giving the ages penalties if they
were not nice to their opponent but the
interesting thing here is that what
we're reporting in this graph obviously
you see that the red lines are at mostly
higher than the blue but but what we're
reporting here is not kind of the team
rewards which of course are going to be
higher but you even do better for
yourself so we're just reporting the one
agent's reward and by using this reward
function which is encouraging the ages
to be friendlier we're making everybody
we're making everybody individually
better off so they're better off in this
setting by being more cooperative all
right so but we don't want to hard-code
the rewards we don't want to manipulate
the system by you know giving humans the
exact encouragement to have it well
maybe we do want to do that but okay
okay
but anyway from the ages what preferable
would be to extract the rewards to
extract the Preferences that are
representative of what you need to
extract preferences that are
representative of the behaviors that
we're observing and so this is exactly
what inverse reinforcement learning does
so when inverse reinforcement learning
you again have an MVP but the rewards
are not specified instead you're given
Zeta and your objective is to back out
the rewards from the data that you
observe so for example one type one way
of solving IRL problems is with maximum
likelihood IRL
so there the goal is exactly what what I
just said you want to find the rewards
the rewards here are represented by this
data you want to find the rewards that
maximize the likelihood of the data so
this is typically done by assuming that
all the sample behaviors are optimal so
we have a bunch of trajectories and we
assume that whoever was demonstrations
was perfect and did everything exactly
right and then we can back out rewards
that would be consistent with the with
those behaviors now there have been some
exceptions to this and we will be
another exception to this so we have
kind of these more generalized IRL model
where what we're assuming is that
trajectories can be labeled as either
positive or negative or maybe even
things in between and so our model our
graphical model looks like this where we
have these labels coming out and that's
part of the data that will be given to
the agents but in addition we assume
that there's some latent variable there
which is on state action pairs and that
latent variable is saying whether one
particular state action but one
particular action taken out of state is
any good or not so the idea being that
if you have a whole bunch of positive
labels on your state action pairs then
you'll end up with a positive label on
the whole trajectory and if you have a
bunch of negatives you would end up with
negative and I'll also note that you
could have a positive label on an entire
trajectory but just identify one
particular action at one particular
state as not being very good okay and
that was actually sort of what we were
going for when we were developing this
model so one of the examples that I have
in mind for this it's not a hallway kind
of example it's just a travel example
but before Michael Wittmann moved to
Brown he was at Rutgers and New Jersey
so I would sometimes have to ask Google
Maps how do I get from Providence to New
Jersey and so Google Maps would give me
the route and I would on the whole want
to label this route as positive because
it was getting me from my goal to my
destination but I started from my source
to my destination so I'm achieving my
goal but the problem was it would very
often take me on this road that's called
the Cross Bronx Expressway I don't know
if any of you have ever been on the
Cross Bronx Expressway but you don't
want to be on the Cross Bronx Expressway
the crossbars resonates probably five
miles
Road north of Manhattan but it's like
it's you've got like these tall walls on
each side of you and you've got trucks
and there are fumes and you can't
breathe and nothing moves you sit there
for an hour it's just terrible so I have
to have the ability to tell Google Maps
or to tell my IRL that I have to exhale
the action of taking the Cross Bronx
Expressway get me from Providence to New
Jersey please to Rutgers but don't take
me on that particular route all right so
this is our model and so we're going to
do maximum likelihood IRL again kind of
assuming that we have these um these
latent labels that are that are
motivating the labels overhaul overall
that we have on our trajectories okay so
I don't think I have time to go into the
details of how we did this but there's
really not that much that's novel here
we're using e/m we're using gradient
gradient ascent we're using important
sampling we're using all of the standard
techniques to to solve this model
alright so so here's just one quick
example of the behavior we observe so
here we have one sample trajectory
through a grid where the goal is this
purple and we've labeled blue is a
puddle so you don't want to be in a
puddle so we've labeled that with this
red to indicate negative and this red
square well we're kind of neutral about
it we don't really care that much one
way or another so that's the label that
we've given so if you look here on the
right you will see the output of our
algorithm on that example and so here
blue means that you've reached your goal
so you can see also on these these
arrows are indicating the optimal policy
so we have the reward function as well
the reward for you can't you can't read
we've never been able to read it sorry
because what it's not big enough but
it's those tiny numbers but what you
can't see as you can see the policy okay
so you can see here in this goal that
we're just kind of deciding to move into
the walls we're happy to be in our goal
that's a good place to be but the most
interesting things part of this and I'm
sorry and red is bad and purple is kind
of neutral the most interesting thing
about this is that here in the bottom
left from that one trajectory the
algorithm has figured out that it wants
to go you know around this puddle this
is kind of a neutral place to be let's
move around it and so as a control we
have just a one trajectory for just a
standard
MLI RL and here we find that a little
bit confused it's maybe thinking that
that's a goal it should say I don't know
what it's thinking but it's not it's not
quite clear that it needs to get out of
there and get around but it doesn't
think it's too expensive as far as it
understands to get all the way to the
goal with that route now this is kind of
a disadvantaged thing right because we
gave a little bit of extra information
to the one algorithm and the other one
still had just the one trajectory maybe
we need to give the other one three
trajectories or five trajectories and it
would it would it would learn just as
well all right running out of time I
want to say that we are bringing this
into the domain of back to our original
domain of the the hallway game and other
games so running and extracting these on
these rewards while they play the game
we're able to you know back out the
rewards and push them forward to see
what the next equilibrium is going to be
so this is like the initial game and
then the final what we haven't done is
we have not brought this into the realm
of humans and robots what we really want
to do is have one of these players be a
human and the other player via robot and
then if the human prefers one
equilibrium or the other it should be
able to tell the robot no I don't like
the equilibrium you're playing that move
you made in that particular state was
not a move that I want you to make and
then it can you know the robot should
replant based on that information and do
whichever equilibrium the human actually
was was heading towards that's that's
our objective alright I'm going to go
quickly alright so first of all I have
to apologize I told you anyway no deep
learning but I did say in my abstract
something very different than what I
actually talked about so I advertised
that we talked about waterless spectrum
auctions and ad exchanges neither of
which I talked about I am happy to talk
to anyone during the day today about
either of these things I've certainly
done some work events I mean the main
thing to say about these application
domains is and it kind of ties back into
what I was talking about at the
beginning about your expression of
preferences so all the optimal auction
theory that I presented was all in a
very special case of a single
dimensional model we had that one v it
was talent or it was your value you had
the one V and when you have that one
dimension you can solve these problems
or at least Meyerson solve the linear
utility problem optimally in these new
these other
problems wireless spectrum and ad
exchanges these are multi-dimensional
problems kind of like the school
preferences I was I was complaining
about you know I couldn't express my
preferences exactly as I wanted to so
these are multi intimate prayer your
preferences have multiple dimensions and
in that case these auction problems are
not well understood not well understood
at all and so you know what we're doing
here this this kind of work is very very
heuristic base we're developing bidding
strategies to try to find equilibria and
sometimes the equilibria don't even
exist right so we're sort of maybe
relaxing our notions of equilibria so we
can find some existence and then running
lots of heuristics to try to even
discover these equilibria so that's
these problems are much harder because
they're in a much higher dimensional
space one thing I wanted to mention
about the combinatorial auctions is that
there's been some new work based on a
combinatorial auction in 2014 that was
run in Canada where they released all
their bidding data so there was a paper
just now at on loss in 2017 where
somebody has created a kind of value
generator so they have they take in the
bidding data and they've somehow
generalized it so that if you ping their
value generator it's like a black box
giving you bids from the distribution
that they have generated and so the
point is that I now have bidding data so
we could try to think about backing out
the values I mean this is much harder
again because we're in this
multi-dimensional space but if we want
to think about the optional the optional
auction problem in this this for this
harder domain we have some bidding data
that we can work from which to me is
very exciting to potentially try to
figure out how we can optimize in this
space okay so really I'm at a time but
happy to talk about ad exchanges as well
with anyone so quick summary I talked a
bit about at least approximately optimal
mechanism design in the case of contest
and we have this may be somewhat
counterintuitive results that you don't
just want to allocate to the top bidders
we also talked a bit about inverse
reinforcement learning and we have a new
and general model which we hope to
potentially deploy on our robots
the main thing about that is that you
have to back out the values that are
motivating the behavior you back out the
values that are motivating the behavior
then you can change the environments and
you can predict how the agent is going
to act in the new environment that's
really what we want to be able to do and
so this this inference process from data
is is very important and driving a lot
of the work that I'm doing okay thank
you all for being you thanks Amy we have
time for a few questions there will be
people walking around the room with
microphones if you just raise your hand
we'll bring a microphone to you I can't
see the number one and thank you for the
fantastic talk I really enjoyed this my
name is Katja Hoffman I'm a researcher
at Microsoft Research in Cambridge and
I'm particularly interested in your work
on human robot I'm wondering how you
think about the incentive structure that
could or should eventually govern those
kinds of interactions do you assume or
should we assume that an AI collaborator
a robot should mimic or kind of align
with the humans reward structure and
utility or should there be a difference
should it have its own incentives that
may or may not be aligned with the with
the human operator that's a very good
question so for what I've been talking
about I was sort of assuming that it
would just be you know what the human
was going to be able to direct the robot
towards something that was satisfying
the human but I could certainly imagine
a world where that is not the case where
we generalize and we somehow give the
robots their own incentives and maybe
allow those incentives to involve to
evolve as well so I think maybe that's a
little bit dangerous but maybe that will
I don't have an example off the top of
my head but I could imagine that that
might actually lead to somehow leads to
even better results for the humans I
mean that's kind of along the lines of
what I was saying before about the
experiment with the Q learners right we
kind of change those rewards in that so
that you are going to be more fair but
that was better for you as well so maybe
we can give
robot some incentives and by letting
them you know they work kind of on their
own behalf they might even benefit us
simultaneously I guess in the end what
I'm saying is I'm very human centric I
want to sit in the end you know be good
for us but be good for us in a way along
the lines of David Carter's question
yesterday in a kind of complimentary way
kind of complementing the goals that
we're trying to achieve number three I
thank you for the talk you talked about
the problem of allocating just to the
top leaders in the sense of discouraging
some of the participants can you talk
about the applications of this result in
education for example in education yeah
well you don't want to discourage
students which you might be struggling
hmm I haven't thought about that but
that seems to be a very good question
hmm you have a comment on that yes yeah
we'll bring a mic down right here I
thought about it mostly in the contest
of Miami a context of my NSF proposal
number two I have a same question but I
don't have a comment although I do want
to probe your theorem a bit more I find
interesting about your reward function
choose this one caught here as the the
top to distribute the rewards and then
the approximation to the optimal bounded
so it's very nice it's 1/16 if I
remember correctly but if I prioritize
your reward function choice of one court
here do I get possibly closer or farther
away yes do you have results to say that
one quarter is actually the Arctic no
know for sure or not yeah so I think we
can do better I we were a little bit
lazy as I said in the math right I
mentioned maybe half and then a quarter
so a quarter worked and we were happy we
got our constant approximation we kind
of quit but I think I think that there's
potentially you can do better but it
doesn't answer the question about what
we're going to do in the realm of
Education so I don't think I know
offhand you have suggestions I'd be
interested I haven't
oughta better but your point is that
maybe some students are not the best
students and so if we're not giving them
AIDS and they might just be discouraged
and quit so we should somehow give
motivation that they could maybe get an
A even if they yeah okay so I can
imagine all sorts of crazy grading
schemes where that could come out so I
think that's an interesting thing to
think about I have not particularly
thought about it but haven't you talked
about it brainstorm about ideas anything
to do to motivate the students to study
harder absolutely yeah okay we have time
for one more question
any last questions before we you take
off okay will join me in thanking a me
for her talk
[Applause]